-You know our next guest
from her work
on "Saturday Night Live"
and movies like "Sisters"
and "Wine Country."
Her new movie,
"A Cluesterfuenke Christmas,"
airs December 4th
on Comedy Central.
Let's take a look.
-Well, where are you coming in
from, hun?
-Uh, New York City.
-Oh!
-Oh, New York.
Never been there myself.
Mnh-mnh.
Too many lights, honking horns.
-Oh, yeah.
-All that hustle and bustle.
-That's a great story.
Could I just get my key?
-Yeah.
-Let me ask you something.
In New York City,
can you see the stars
when you look up at the sky?
-Uh, not really.
Not with all the lights.
-No stars?
How are you gonna make a wish?
[ Laughter ]
-Please welcome back to the show
our friend Rachel Dratch.
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
Resplendent.
Look at you, Dratch.
-I'm wearing Christmas sparkles.
-You always sparkle.
-It's not even Thanksgiving.
Yes.
-You sparkle every season.
-Oh, thank you, Seth.
It's good to be here.
-It's great to have you here.
-Thank you.
-So, this was the first time
I was at a movie theater
in almost two years.
I went to the screening of
this film on Sunday night.
It was so much fun.
-Thank you.
-It was so much fun for me.
And I can't imagine how much fun
it was for you
to hear it with an audience.
-Yeah, we had never seen this
with an audience,
and people were laughing a lot,
so it was a lot of fun. Yes.
-You had one audience member
where the stakes
were a little bit higher.
Your 11-year-old son, Eli.
-Yes, I took Eli.
I don't usually take him --
I haven't done anything in
a long time that would be, like,
you know, kid-friendly.
-Appropriate, sure.
-And I didn't know how he was
going to like it.
So, this is a parody of
a Hallmark Christmas movie.
-Yes. A loving parody,
it should be noted.
A lot of people
from the Hallmark world
actually helped make the film.
-Well, yeah, we had
this one guy, who --
Michael Murray, who's written
like 20 Hallmark movies.
This movie was not sanctioned by
Hallmark, though.
It has nothing to do --
So don't sue us, Hallmark.
It's just the idea.
-As greeting-card companies go,
the most litigious.
[ Laughter ]
-It's just the idea of
a Hallmark movie.
But, anyway, yeah -- but, so,
Eli -- I told him, you know,
"Here are the basics of
one of these real movies."
And he really liked it.
He was laughing a lot.
-That's great.
-Yeah.
-'Cause we've talked before,
you have showed
him "SNL" sketches
from your time that maybe
haven't always gone over
that well.
-Well, I tried to show him --
When he was, like, seven
I tried to show him
the original "Debbie Downer,"
and he sort of, like,
checked out halfway through.
And then I didn't try again
since then.
I should try, though.
-Of course that even showing
the "Debbie Downer" sketch is
somehow a Debbie Downer moment.
[ Laughter ]
-Exactly, yeah.
-Here, look. There.
We'll take that single.
Say, he didn't -- you showed it
to him and then look there
and say he didn't like it.
-He checked out halfway through.
[ Laughter, cheers
and applause ]
Can't even entertain my own kid.
Yeah.
-It's cluster-- So, there's
umlauts over both U's.
So I think it should be
Cluesterfuenke.
-I heard we have a German
and an Austrian here,
so there's some umlauts
in the audience.
-They laughed when they heard
how I pronounced it.
They're like,
"That's not how --"
-And also that wasn't
on the air.
That wasn't on air. That was in
the preshow. Anyway. Cut that.
-Yeah, Rachel is referring
the crowd work that we do.
[ Laughter ]
-I listen to every moment,
including the crowd work.
No. "Cluesterfuenke" -- We threw
in some umlauts for comedy.
But, yeah, the last name
of the --
Ana and I play
the Cluesterfuenke sisters.
-Yes. Whose idea was it to cast
you as sort of aunts
who own an inn?
-Okay, so, you know, we knew
we weren't going to be, like,
the executive who shows up
from the city to fall in love.
It wasn't going to be that.
So it was so funny
'cause we were talking about,
"What are we going to play?"
And it was like,
"Oh, we're playing the spinster
aunts who run the inn."
They were like, "Oh, yeah."
There was no question.
It wasn't even a discussion.
It was just like,
"We good with this?" "Yeah."
And then like,
"Bring on the gray buns."
It was like --
We knew we were going to have,
like, gray buns, glasses.
It was so fun,
'cause it was like "SNL" style.
Sometimes when you're
in a movie, you can't be
as broad as you would like
to be, like "SNL" style.
You have to play it real.
This was so fun
'cause we got to be like --
-Yes, the minute we see you,
there's not a sense of like,
"I feel like this is gonna
dig down to what it's like
to be an aunt who owns an inn."
-Exactly.
[ Laughter ]
-I heard there was a phrase that
you personally
really wanted to get
in the film.
-Right, so, for these
"Hallmark-esque" movies,
there's all these tropes,
and, like, things to hit
to make it seem real.
So, anyway, there's one thing --
Like, in all these romantic
comedies, someone always says --
Like, someone asks someone
on a date,
and then the woman goes,
"I'd like that."
[ Laughter ]
And so, I hate that.
I hate "I like that."
So I would say that to Tina
sometimes, like,
when we're just like, "Do you
want to come over to --"
I'm like, "I'd like that."
[ Laughter ]
But so I know we had to throw
"I'd like that" in there.
So that's a little, like, find
"I'd like that" in the movie.
-There are -- Were there other,
like, clichés from this
sort of, you know,
non-branded holiday show?
-Right, so, I mean, there's
several -- there's, like, a --
[ Laughter ]
There's like a few plot lines.
-The next Hallmark card you get,
you're going to open it up,
and there's going to be
a summons.
-"You've been sued." Exactly.
[ Laughter ]
So, there's, like, five basic
plots, but the number one is,
like, big-city, bitchy executive
who doesn't have time for love
or Christmas gets sent to
small town and meets, you know,
small-town, like, woodsman
or fireman or whatever.
[ Laughter ]
And then, like, falls in love.
She's there to, like, take over
a business, a quaint business.
And then she falls in love and
finds the spirit of Christmas.
Not to ruin the movie, but --
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-So that's what it was.
So we picked that
as our main plot.
But we also had,
like, a magical dog.
You know, there's, like,
things we threw in.
-It's very self-aware, but I
think the part that delighted me
the most the longer I watched
was realizing,
"Oh, this is also
a Christmas movie."
And I like Christmas movies.
-Yeah.
-And everybody in it is great.
-Yeah, I think it plays on
two levels,
'cause we made sure to make
the love story kind of real.
So, if you like these movies
or if you can't stand them,
I think there's something
for everyone
in "A Cluesterfuenke Christmas."
-I think that's true,
and you mentioned --
I don't know if you mentioned
it here --
but you mentioned,
before you introduced it,
where you shot it and what time
of year you shot it.
-Oh, right.
So, all of these movies
shoot in Vancouver in July.
That's real.
[ Laughter ]
So, you know, there's fake snow
everywhere.
I learned a lot about fake snow
'cause it's, like,
there's a blanket,
like, a white blanket.
That's one part,
and then there's someone --
There's, like, the "snow person"
in Vancouver
who comes with a truck and puts
snow all along the edge.
So that's a whole science.
Yeah, there --
So there's a few little moments
where we make sure you see that
this is in Canada in our movie.
-Yeah. I really -- I like that
you introduced it with that,
because you are wearing so many
sweaters and so much gray bun.
And when I thought about
the fact
that it was like 90 degrees.
-We were there in the heat wave.
And it was, yeah, it was a lot.
But everyone made it through.
Yeah.
-Everybody made it out?
-Yeah.
-Thank you so much
for being here.
-My gosh, it always goes
so fast.
-It goes so fast!
-It goes so fast.
-It is always the best to see
Rachel Dratch, everybody.
"A Cluesterfuenke Christmas"
airs December 4th
on Comedy Central.